[Music]
in 1975 I saw a Tesla coil that a
neighbor had built a little one and I
was really fascinated with it because it
was aesthetically beautiful and it made
electricity jump into the air which I
thought was really amazing
I built this giant coil in 1991 and 1992
at UC Berkeley when I was a graduate
student there in physics and in 1996 I
had the idea to build a cage and get
inside of it and have the Tesla coil
strike the cage and when I did that I
didn't feel any sensation of electricity
so then I while I was in the cage I
touched the inside of the cage with my
hands and I didn't get a shot so that's
when I realized that I could shrink the
cage down to make a bodysuit and it
would be okay if the metal was touching
my skin the machine is a Tesla coil and
it is generating electricity with it
with about a voltage of about 200,000
volts and the coil is firing at about
500 times a second so it's actually a
bunch of pulses
in quick succession and that's how you
can get such long sparks because the
pulse is essentially it drills a hole
through the air or just its own wire
through the air that's how you can get
such long electric arcs out of it
this suit is made out of a stainless
steel knit mesh it's a fabric that's
used for industrial straining processes
usually this is a piece of heating duct
cut open to make this chest armor and
this is a birdcage on top and all these
components are connected together
electrically including these gloves
which are meat cutters gloves made out
of stainless steel chain maille and then
these are aluminum foot guards so the
electricity runs on the outside of the
suit because of something called the
skin effect which says that
high-frequency electricity tends to run
on the outside of conductors so I have
no sensation whatsoever of electricity
inside the suit I don't feel it at all
[Applause]